yo
you wanna see that thing yang when the
dude asks him he's like can you choke a
[ __ ] with your timbers during sex
wait wait you haven't seen this video no
no i saw him i saw him get kicked out of
that rally he was at a black lives
matter rally and they
they booted him bro i'm tired of these
[ __ ] you know why
because he wouldn't let him get their
fifth house this [ __ ] wait a
minute wait a minute wait wait hold up
there's so many things going on
andrew yang first of all get this video
up
it's this dude is asking him i think
charlotte posted on his on his
instagram but the dude asks him yo um is
it okay to keep your tim's on when
you're like choking a [ __ ] during sex
or something like that
and he answered the question super
diplomatically i think it was broken
like he goes he goes uh i think that's
between you and the girl
i think that if she's cool with it
that's fine and then the guy kept on
going and he laughed
and of course the people who do not want
andrew yang to be mayor latched onto
that [ __ ] they're like
mayoral candidate andrew yang is
laughing at misogynistic humor
oh some people make a living doing that
and there's nothing wrong with it and it
can provide a nice lifestyle do you have
that uh
that video about yeah all right here it
is the realest question
that's ever been asked to a mayoral
candidate of new york can a man keep his
timber
can a man keep the tim's on yeah
[Laughter]
he goes he goes can a man keeps his
tim's home while he's [ __ ] and i
think and then andrew yang
diplomatically goes
i and first of all i'm a north andrew
gang because
him and his publicist refused to come on
flanker 2 podcast they're not as brave
as we've been yang gang and we were
yanking be loyal yo
actually i've never been yanking i'm
yang gang bro i don't believe in that
give people money and then they vote for
your [ __ ]
give me money i ain't voting otherwise
second i'm voting otherwise you might as
well pay me all right
now he's coming up so we were trying to
get him on but he's been ducking and
there's no way he's going to do a
flagrant interview after this [ __ ]
that's [ __ ]
done so the guy goes um well you guys
heard it
what do you guys think i thought he
handled it it's purely up to your
partner that's perfect alliteration the
next one
is when he goes you choke [ __ ] he
goes you choke [ __ ] and he just
starts laughing and moving away
how do you not laugh at that that's a
hysterical thing to ask
a future [ __ ] mayor potentially
what's he supposed to do
hey yo i don't think that's an
appropriate question [ __ ] you if you do
that yeah
then [ __ ] him now if i'm him i would
just say i wouldn't use that word
i don't call women the b word or
something if i'm him
right like that's i think where people
are getting pissed well it depends who
you
who you're choking bro maybe his wife
you don't know how that girl identifies
no she sees herself as a [ __ ] yeah it's
that
that's my point like if the issue i
think what people are taking with this
they're like oh
mayor can't be talking about [ __ ] so
he just has to say
yeah you can choke whoever if they're
consensual blah blah just i wouldn't use
that word
that's all you gotta say right you sound
like a liberal [ __ ]
it's one thing if he came to the mayor's
mansion no he's going into the streets
with people
there's gonna be different people
talking about different things and and
he went on on
this guy's street this is a young comic
of african-americans yeah can we uh
how do i get out of the guy he was on
his
his block this guy's trying to make a
living yo [ __ ] bagel bite dude
and he was on this gentleman my deli is
right behind there yeah
this gentleman's street it was on this
gentleman's street which we own all the
buildings and
chargers quite frankly he can't afford
he had a place
he's on the street from now until you
know people move in and kick him out but
uh you know
um i don't know i think it's just so
corny to like smear yang
based on this i think that's whack why
are they trying to get yanked so hard
why do liberals hate yang
maybe because yang represents and i
never thought about this
i never thought of him as this before
but maybe because yang represents like
the kind of bernie clan
in a way like he's like yeah let's give
universal basic income let's just give
[ __ ] money away
and maybe the democrats that are like
kind of like fake democrats like the
biden democrats
they're not really democrats like
socially democrat about some [ __ ] but
yeah let's just go to war those
democrats
the kamalas and stuff like yeah maybe
they're like yo
we don't need the aoc stuff we don't
need any of that like
what they view as like democratic
socialism creeping in
i've also seen the other side on twitter
criticizing him he made that video on a
bodega
and everybody's like you don't even
that's not even a real bodega he doesn't
know the bodega
shut the [ __ ] up dude you [ __ ] loser
he's trying to say support independent
business and then he had a tweet series
saying like
i don't want unlicensed vendors in new
york city selling stuff on the streets i
want to try to help them get licenses
and then the same super far left people
were like he's trying to cut off people
trying to make a living income blah blah
blah it's like doug he's
he didn't even read the second tweet he
sounds liberal with universal basic
income because he's saying it from the
point of view as a pragmatist he's a
he worked in technology that's it so
everyone else is like no it's a
socialist idea redistribution wealth all
of this he's just like this is how you
plug the leak this is how we can get
back and
make things more fair but i think just
as a pragmatist let's not analyze him as
anyone that
is standing behind a super set of
liberality that's why i love him
he's a robot dog yeah and he knows
robots are going to take our jobs he's
like we got to do something in the
meantime here's a little money to hold
us over this is what it's going to be
al i'm for ray mcguire
you like right he literally just looked
up the black guy's name not on him
that's eric adams eric adams is the
black guy he's later you're not voting
for the black guy out
do you want to know what the bible did
you want to know what he did google you
know eric adams or ray mcguire
right he googled jay-z endorsement of
new york
because i couldn't remember his day but
i know jc and jordan i saw you look up
you said i'm going for ray mcguire i saw
you look up and think about it in the
top of your brain
you're pulling down he's my guy yeah
he's black
he's my guy yeah he's what do you like
what do you like about ray mcguire jay-z
why do you think jay's supporting him i
don't know i we've been out of new york
so long i don't know what's going on
you're not even i haven't even
paid attention second place is eric
adams and these are the democratic
primaries and whoever wins the primary
in june
is going to win i leadership i love eric
adams though yeah
i love that man wait why do you love him
because he's strong
yeah yeah he's strict he wears his teams
he nah
he's being [ __ ] he doesn't believe in
tim's hey really he won't even let his
kids have tim's bro he he showed you how
to go around your kid's room and find if
they got tim's that's really crazy
he's not gonna like it you don't think
he's getting elected that guy's going to
say
and we're gonna make it happen if he
don't support tim's i don't know if he
can if you don't support this podcast
you can't be mayor of new york
so let's hit up ray i'll hit up ray i'll
hit up eric
yo like i said my vote could be a
thousand dollars a day motherfucker's
name again
andrew yang yeah whatever his name is to
give the money bro he's treating us all
like we're starving kids in africa bro
what is this why is he doing that to us
yeah like why you don't treat us like
that bro is that who we are to you
in the arms of an 8000 day sounds pretty
nice that's kind of it
like i mean that's kind of legit i mean
if he read or not
that's a good policy i got my book yeah
i switched that up but not i don't want
a thousand dollars
if everybody else got that i wanted just
me
so i could stunt right i'm supposed to
stun if everybody got the same [ __ ]
that's a good point right then they
gonna go to all the restaurants oh
[ __ ] then i can't damn what let me tell
you something coming back baby by the
way no i'm ready for new year and i do
feel new york's gonna be back
and miami's starting to get hot like
i caught a heatstroke i was working
outside i was i was working out outside
so annoying so i almost called it a heat
stroke y'all ever had heat stroke it's
crazy yeah i was
no dude i almost caught a heat stroke
which one is the jewish person here
heat stroke bro i literally was i was
working out and i'm [ __ ] stroking he
caught me bro
getting stroked i literally almost
caught a heat stroke bro
i was i was doing the pads and then i i
i literally i took one hand i went oh i
put my pad
up on my forehead like that and the
heatstroke got me dude
while the jewish guy was inside in the
ac that's how you know he's still
listening
yeah i was out there dog trying i was
out there hitting them pads bro
cause someone need to check jake someone
needs to ain't gonna be me but someone
didn't check
jake i think you could do it no jake
jake i get knocked out for jake but for
50 million
yo 50 million guaranteed
let's go we dancing we're dancing
that would be a fun time straight into
the gym put on low weight
training for 17 years this is my ankles
don't even work no more bro
now jacob big boy when we saw him i was
like this [ __ ] big
logan i think is bigger yeah yeah logan
is like taller but jake i was like oh he
for his
height is a big dude yeah yeah so are
you over miami or what
no you're going to heat stroke that i
timed this perfectly right i started
getting heatstroke end of
april yeah if we left
may 1st and went back i'd be like man i
still miss miami yeah you want a little
stroke
i want to be ready to go back i want it
to be like mid-may we're like now we're
ready for new york
it's like boom yeah yes you see me you
feel what i'm saying i like it
it's going to be gorge we're going to go
back to new york we're like ah beautiful
cool city's going to be ready to go
[ __ ] great gatsby [ __ ] we're going to
roll in
go right to the waldorf [ __ ] in the
wall door
not [ __ ] but uh
all right i got [ __ ] in the waldorf
put my fur over the couch
wait a minute
don't even park it leave that [ __ ] in
front of the wall door yeah
uh-huh all right that's valet guys say
what what cute ass valet
with the hips yeah with the hips what
size weighs to you uh huh that's what i
said what size waste dude he's like what
i say don't park it leave it right there
yeah all right little schmucker's jelly
[Laughter]
spread you on son yeah
i don't care i got bubbly in the bathtub
back to [ __ ] in the wall door
[ __ ] in the wall okay i'm back okay
i'm back [ __ ] is in the wall door
bubbly in the bathtub
bugatti pop bugatti downstairs oh i call
it yo can you bring a car
psych is already there um smokers room
service
room services cute ass little mexican
dude adorable [ __ ]
what's he bringing you huh what's he
bringing you [ __ ] more [ __ ]
grab that ankle
that's what he don't break me you know
what i mean but he but he
what else he like left that came back to
this party like three times already
[Music]
we got [ __ ] in the wall we got
mexican guy bringing a little
silver [ __ ] with the ice with the nice
lips icing it with the fat lips and a
nice little mustache
just perfectly trimmed so you can focus
on the lips yeah you know what i'm
saying
give me that egg benedict give me a go
give me that choose roll
with a little boost to the
[ __ ] in the wall door
salad
okay uh what rhymes with waldorf come on
you're good at this
tall [ __ ] oh [ __ ] in the waldorf
hey only got the tall horse
frozen pork oh [ __ ] in the waldorf
yeah you only got the tall horse eating
on the roast pork
oh with the uh
we waited out the snowstorms oh my gosh
huh yeah yo we're in the subway show
what's up ladies and gentlemen show this
show
[ __ ] into waldorf bringing out the
tall horse
horse was a nice one brushed with some
roast pork broth with some roast pork
avoided all the snow storms uh
grab a chick by her long finger
that means you're going to marry her
grab a chick by
yeah yeah i might as well put a ring on
her we'll put a ring
in her nova more angrier you're gonna
wrote another humdinger
look at the ceiling see the
constellations
action bronson exactly look at this look
at the silence to the constellation
orion's belt kind of look like that
mexican dude that brought the [ __ ]
tray of fabric sizes to their own
yeah that's what my iq was like after
taking that backseat
this [ __ ] hit the big dipper you point
down to 77.
take the wonder lick right now probably
lick it
that was bars bro [ __ ] in the wall
door there we go
[Laughter]
it's a horse tall horse you don't know
which one it is i don't know
oh pop that ace cork oh pot that ace
cork
come on we need some help oh we a bunch
of big dorks
damn why are you so good at writing
[ __ ] lyrics bro they're kind of
ourselves
reluctantly you got it what's that
what's the name of that you guys people
that wrote all the plays back in the day
you harlow over here
we do know the the rap bars of jews
simon simon what's the other guy beastie
boys
publisher what yeah simon schuster the
publisher yeah
yo all right ready let's do it [ __ ] is
in the ball door oh we back let's go
all right let's get off of waldorf
that's this that's hard yeah
plaza oh that's another one peter luger
got the bugatti in his orange oh
mark god damn it's so hard to wrap
orange yeah my bad
okay okay ready ready ready ready hold
on we got this let's go let's hit this
are you ready for this plaza no we're
hitting this
all right all right all right all right
all right peter lugar see your bits of
mike steeler
uh yeah i'm with two real dudes
harvard and tequila
[Laughter]
okay okay i'm with you yeah i was done
he was doing it i i i was junior
judy all right all right ready all right
wait wait what was it again what was
that doing to peter louis luger
okay who dudes with you ava havah and
the guillotine
put that truffle on that matzah uh
you want to make it all jewish i can't
go all day guys
yeah yeah yeah put some tandoori chicken
on it bro
oh that's not too oh we were going
multicultural bro
wrappers right now we're taking it to
the next level yeah
al can you just just re-center us please
because you're the tesseract here
for rap we have to draw all of our
energy from you okay you're our rapture
you're our vision yes rescue our north
star
[ __ ] in the wall door
tonight what are we doing tonight
what's going down tonight al i think we
might have some [ __ ] in the world
though now you know you got to hit it
wrong why are you saying it's on me yeah
yeah yeah the strength black rob
how would black rob say it america
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
leave sperm on abdomen only chicks and
no guys
never guys yeah that's great not even
maybe one time we made a mistake
but it's fine yeah only girls it's
straight porn
what about this rap i want to talk about
some soccer [ __ ] right
this is the biggest story in the world
take it away in the world
yo son you can't say that that bar don't
hit you
hit y'all that's a ball i wish i wish
you chose a different hotel
to be honest knock us on wall doors it
happens or it hits
it's just don't arrive with it and now
you can say we're bringing ronaldo
and neymar and messi to the waldorf
waldorf yeah
you